Attention deficit hyperactivity disorder, or ADHD, was originally thought of as a disorder of childhood. And for many people, the image that comes to mind when they think of ADHD is an eight-year-old boy who can't sit still in class. But in recent decades, scientists have gained a more sophisticated understanding of the causes of ADHD and have begun to realize that it can be a lifelong disorder with lifelong consequences. Estimates of the prevalence of ADHD vary, but data from the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention found that in 2019, 8.8% of all children, ages 3 to 17, had ever received a diagnosis of ADHD. That prevalence has risen fairly steadily since the 1990s. How has our understanding of ADHD changed
注意力缺陷多动障碍，即ADHD，最初被认为是一种儿童期疾病。对于许多人来说，提到ADHD时脑海中浮现的形象是一个在课堂上坐不住的八岁男孩。但在近几十年来，科学家们对ADHD的成因有了更深入的了解，并开始意识到这可能是一种终身疾病，会产生终身影响。关于ADHD患病率的估计各不相同，但美国疾病控制与预防中心的数据显示，2019年，3至17岁的所有儿童中，有8.8%的人曾被诊断出患有ADHD。自20世纪90年代以来，这一患病率一直在稳步上升。我们对ADHD的理解在这些年里发生了怎样的变化？
over those years? What do we know about how it looks in childhood, adolescence, and adulthood? Is it possible to develop ADHD as an adult? What are the most effective treatments? And how has the pandemic affected children and adults with a disorder? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Maggie Sibley, a clinical psychologist at Seattle Children's Hospital, and an associate professor of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at the University of Washington School of Medicine.
我们对它在儿童期、青春期和成年期的表现了解多少？成年后患上ADHD有可能吗？最有效的治疗方法是什么？疫情又是如何影响患有这种疾病的儿童和成人的？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是西雅图儿童医院的临床心理学家、华盛顿大学医学院精神病学和行为科学副教授玛吉·西布利博士。
Dr. Sibley's work focuses on the diagnosis and treatment of ADHD in adolescents and young adults. She's developed a treatment therapy called Stand, supporting teens' autonomy daily, to help teens with ADHD and their parents. She's also co-authored more than 75 scientific papers on ADHD, including a recent study that found for most people diagnosed as children, ADHD symptoms continue into adulthood. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Sibley. I'm happy to be here. Let's start with the basics. I mentioned in the introduction that many people have a mental image of a person with ADHD as a high. hyperactive young child, usually a boy who can't pay attention in class. But that's a very
西布利博士的工作重点是青少年和年轻成人的ADHD诊断与治疗。她开发了一种名为“STAND”（每日支持青少年自主权）的治疗方案，旨在帮助患有ADHD的青少年及其父母。她还合著了75多篇关于ADHD的科学论文，其中包括最近的一项研究，该研究发现，对于大多数在儿童时期被诊断出患有ADHD的人来说，ADHD症状会持续到成年。感谢您今天加入我们，西布利博士。很高兴来到这里。让我们从基础知识开始。我在介绍中提到，许多人对ADHD患者的心理印象是一个高度多动的幼儿，通常是一个在课堂上无法集中注意力的男孩。但这只是一个非常
incomplete picture of ADHD. Can you tell us a little more about what ADHD actually entails how it's defined and how it's diagnosed? So ADHD is a disorder with biological underpinnings. And we've done decades of research now that shows that there is a genetic component to ADHD for many people and that the genes that seem to be related to ADHD are related to the chemical in the brain called dopamine. And dopamine is a chemical in your brain that modulates your response to rewards. And so people with ADHD may have trouble regulating their attention, may have trouble being motivated, may have trouble with controlling their cognition, because the chemical in their brain dopamine is working a little bit differently than it is for the average person.
不完整的ADHD图景。您能多告诉我们一些关于ADHD的实际含义、它是如何定义以及如何诊断的吗？ADHD是一种具有生物学基础的疾病。我们现在已经进行了几十年的研究，表明对于许多人来说，ADHD存在遗传因素，而且似乎与ADHD相关的基因与大脑中一种叫做多巴胺的化学物质有关。多巴胺是大脑中调节你对奖励反应的化学物质。因此，ADHD患者可能在调节注意力方面有困难，可能在保持动力方面有困难，也可能在控制认知方面有困难，因为他们大脑中的多巴胺化学物质的工作方式与普通人略有不同。
And so in young children, you're going to see this translate into trouble controlling your behavior and hyperactivity and trouble paying attention in school. But as people get older, you're going to see the symptoms of ADHD change a little bit. In adolescence, you're going to see the hyperactivity go down. And a lot more of the impairment has to do with your attention control and your ability to stay organized and stay motivated and overcome things like procrastination. And even in adulthood, the disorder changes even more. And you're going to see people struggle with things like staying on top of their finances, being able to hold down a steady job, stay on task, being able to do work that sometimes isn't the most appealing and keep themselves
因此，在幼儿身上，你会看到这转化为控制行为的困难、多动以及在学校注意力不集中的问题。但随着年龄的增长，你会看到ADHD的症状发生了一些变化。在青春期，你会看到多动症有所减少。更多的障碍与你的注意力控制、保持组织性、保持动力以及克服拖延症等问题有关。即使在成年期，这种疾病的变化甚至更大。你会看到人们在处理财务、保持稳定工作、专注于任务、完成有时并不那么吸引人的工作以及保持自我
motivated. So it's really that link of being able to control the way you think and the way you act that strings together what ADHD is across the lifespan. So there are factors that have to be present, though, in order for somebody to get a real clinical diagnosis of ADHD. Can you talk about what those are? Sure. So in order to be diagnosed with ADHD, you have to show this pattern of behavior that is related to attention and motivation and cognitive control. But at the same time, those difficulties have to be severe enough that they actually cause a real problem in a person's life. So everyone may have tendencies to sometimes have trouble staying on task or focusing sometimes, but a person with ADHD is going to experience that in multiple settings. So whether it's at home
动力方面挣扎。因此，正是这种控制思维和行为方式的能力，将ADHD在整个生命周期中的表现串联了起来。不过，要让某人获得真正的ADHD临床诊断，必须具备一些因素。您能谈谈这些因素是什么吗？当然。为了被诊断出患有ADHD，你必须表现出与注意力、动力和认知控制相关的行为模式。但与此同时，这些困难必须严重到足以在人的生活中造成真正的问题。每个人有时可能都有难以保持专注或集中注意力的倾向，但ADHD患者会在多种环境中经历这种情况。无论是在家里
and at work or at school and with social activities, you're going to see it in a pattern across your life. And you're also going to see that impairment. It's going to mean that you're going to have real problems in your life because of these symptoms. It's going to be for people in school, their grades aren't as high as they could be. For people who have jobs, they might have trouble holding down the jobs. Socially, you might find yourself with problematic relationships with other people or difficulty holding down a romantic relationship because you're having trouble controlling your thoughts and your behaviors. You published a paper in August that found only about 10% of people diagnosed with ADHD as children will grow out of it as adults.
还是在工作中，或者在学校和社交活动中，你都会在生活中看到这种模式。你还会看到这种障碍。这意味着由于这些症状，你的生活中会出现真正的问题。对于在校学生来说，他们的成绩可能不如预期；对于有工作的人来说，他们可能难以保住工作；在社交方面，你可能会发现自己与他人的关系出现问题，或者因为难以控制自己的思想和行为而难以维持一段浪漫关系。您在八月份发表了一篇论文，发现只有约10%在儿童时期被诊断出患有ADHD的人在成年后会摆脱它。
Can you talk about that research? So I'm lucky to be a part of the multimodal treatment study of ADHD, which was a big study done in the 1990s where about 500 children with ADHD got different treatments, medication treatments, behavioral treatments, and a little bit of both for some of the groups. And then these children were followed until fairly recently until they were about age 25. And so we were able to, every two years or so, check in, find out what the symptoms and the functioning of these kids were like by asking their parents, by asking their teachers, by asking themselves. And with that really complete picture of how their ADHD was changing over time, what we saw was that there's only about 10% of this group of children who continue to steadily have a high level of ADHD all the way to age 25.
您能谈谈这项研究吗？我很幸运能参与ADHD多模式治疗研究，这是一项在20世纪90年代进行的大型研究，大约500名患有ADHD的儿童接受了不同的治疗，包括药物治疗、行为治疗，以及一些小组结合了两者。然后，这些孩子被跟踪研究直到最近，大约25岁。因此，我们能够每两年左右进行一次检查，通过询问他们的父母、老师以及他们自己，了解这些孩子的症状和功能状况。通过对他们的ADHD随时间变化的完整了解，我们发现，这组儿童中只有约10%的人一直到25岁都持续保持高水平的ADHD。
there's about another 10% who seem to have pretty steadily overcome their ADHD and stayed recovered. And then most of the other people are somewhere in the middle where their ADHD seems to go up or down over time, depending on their circumstances. So there might be some years of their life where the ADHD actually looked more severe than other years. And if that's the case, that opens up a lot of questions about, well, what causes those fluctuations, and are we really surprised that most people are still struggling with ADHD long term? I don't think so because as a disorder with a biological underpinning, that's chronic, just like diabetes or anything else that you're born with that you kind of struggle with for
大约还有10%的人似乎相当稳定地克服了他们的ADHD并保持康复。而其他大多数人则处于中间地带，他们的ADHD症状似乎随时间而波动，具体取决于他们的情况。因此，他们生命中可能有些年份的ADHD看起来比其他年份更严重。如果是这样的话，这就引出了很多问题，比如，是什么导致了这些波动？我们是否真的对大多数人长期仍在与ADHD作斗争感到惊讶？我不这么认为，因为作为一种具有生物学基础的慢性疾病，就像糖尿病或任何你与生俱来并伴随你
your life, you wouldn't expect it to just go away, even though we can learn to manage it and have folks do a lot better. And all the people in this study, were they in treatment at the time? Well, at the time of the study, they were given treatments as a part of the study. And so they all got 14 months of treatment. And then after that, they no longer got treatments from the research team, but of course, many of them went and got treatment out in their communities, whether it was medication or seeing a psychologist and getting therapy. And so there's still an open question about what role treatment has in helping people overcome their symptoms. But we do have evidence-based treatments for ADHD that help people both in the short term and in the long term. So certainly that's a piece of the picture. Now, there's been a rise in recent years in the number of people being diagnosed with ADHD for the first time in adulthood. Is it possible to develop ADHD as an adult or did the people who are being diagnosed as adults probably have it as children but just weren't diagnosed at the time?
一生的疾病一样，你不会指望它会消失，尽管我们可以学会管理它，并让人们做得更好。这项研究中的所有人在当时都在接受治疗吗？嗯，在研究期间，他们作为研究的一部分接受了治疗。所以他们都接受了14个月的治疗。在那之后，他们不再接受研究团队的治疗，但当然，他们中的许多人去社区寻求了治疗，无论是药物治疗还是看心理医生并接受治疗。因此，关于治疗在帮助人们克服症状方面起什么作用，仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。但我们确实有针对ADHD的循证治疗方法，可以在短期和长期内帮助人们。所以这当然是其中的一部分。现在，近年来首次在成年期被诊断出患有ADHD的人数有所增加。成年后患上ADHD有可能吗？还是说那些被诊断为成人的患者可能在儿童时期就患有此病，只是当时没有被诊断出来？
This is a really interesting question. So first of all, we think there's a big group that I would call late-identified ADHD, which means they probably had ADHD or tendencies that are similar to ADHD the whole time. But for various reasons, they were not noticed until they were an adult and they were able to speak up for themselves. And we already know some of the factors that can lead to that. For example, ADHD is a lot less recognized in girls and women because they aren't so hyperactive and loud about their symptoms. And so sometimes people think that they're just a little bit spacey and they don't actually get the diagnosis. We also know in people of color or people who might come from cultures where mental health difficulties are not recognized as mental health
这是一个非常有趣的问题。首先，我们认为有一个很大的群体，我会称之为“晚期识别的ADHD”，这意味着他们可能一直都有ADHD或类似的倾向。但由于各种原因，直到他们成年并能够为自己发声时才被注意到。我们已经知道一些可能导致这种情况的因素。例如，ADHD在女孩和女性中识别度要低得多，因为她们不像男孩那样多动，症状也不那么明显。所以有时人们认为她们只是有点走神，实际上并没有得到诊断。我们也知道，在有色人种或来自心理健康困难不被视为心理健康
difficulties that they may not come to the attention of professionals or be recognized as well. So certainly better recognition in our school systems where educators are learning to keep their eyes out for kids who are struggling in this area has helped us learn to see kids at an earlier age that may have ADHD, but still we have a 3% rate of ADHD in adulthood overall. And as you were saying, something like 8% in childhood. So if you agree that ADHD is a chronic disorder, we're still missing a lot of people, even though maybe now we're capturing more people. Can it come on as an adult and never have any symptoms earlier?
困难的文化背景的人中，他们可能不会引起专业人士的注意，或者没有得到很好的识别。因此，我们的学校系统在教育工作者学习关注这一领域挣扎的孩子方面做得更好，这确实帮助我们在更早的年龄发现可能患有ADHD的孩子，但总体而言，成年期的ADHD患病率仍为3%。正如你所说，儿童期约为8%。所以如果你同意ADHD是一种慢性疾病，那么即使我们现在可能捕捉到了更多的人，我们仍然漏掉了很多人。它能在成年后出现，而之前从未有过任何症状吗？
That's still a bit of a debated question. I think it depends on how you define ADHD. because if you consider any difficulties with paying attention or focusing or, you know, controlling your behavior or your thoughts as a form of ADHD, you might be able to say yes, because we know things like going through trauma or things like having experiences, maybe even where you were involved with substances and then you stopped can impact your cognition in ways that look like ADHD. There's a lot of ADHD mimics out there. And so it's really important when people are getting diagnosed as adults that they go to a professional who can tell the difference between kind of our classic ADHD that has that biological underpinning and starts in childhood and something else that has a similar symptoms but might have a different source of where it came from.
这仍然是一个有争议的问题。我认为这取决于你如何定义ADHD。因为如果你认为任何注意力不集中、难以专注，或者控制行为或思想的困难都算作一种ADHD，你也许可以说“是”，因为我们知道经历创伤或经历过某些事情，甚至可能涉及物质使用然后停止，都会以看起来像ADHD的方式影响你的认知。外面有很多ADHD的“模仿者”。因此，当人们在成年后被诊断时，去咨询一位能够区分具有生物学基础并始于儿童期的经典ADHD，与具有相似症状但来源可能不同的其他疾病的专业人士，是非常重要的。
So speaking of prevalence, there's an idea out there that's been around for years that ADHD is overdiagnosed and that some children are given medication when they don't really need it. I mean, isn't it just the nature of childhood that some kids? kids are rambunctious and have trouble paying attention in school and mightn't it be a case of overworked and overburdened parents who want something to control their children because they can't do it themselves. Are these valid concerns? I like to say that ADHD is misdiagnosed, not over or underdiagnosed. Because like we just talked about, there are some people who are being missed and there are also some people who may be being given a diagnosis somewhat liberally. And I think that that is up to any individual provider about how confident they are when they make an ADHD diagnosis and how severe a symptom presentation that provider feels they need to see in order to give the diagnosis.
说到患病率，有一种流传多年的观点认为ADHD被过度诊断了，一些孩子在不需要的情况下被给予了药物。我的意思是，有些孩子顽皮、在学校难以集中注意力，这难道不是童年的天性吗？这会不会是过度劳累、负担过重的父母想要某种东西来控制他们的孩子，因为他们自己做不到？这些担忧有道理吗？我喜欢说ADHD是被“误诊”了，而不是过度或不足诊断。因为正如我们刚才所谈到的，有些人被漏诊了，也有一些人可能被相当随意地给予了诊断。我认为这取决于任何个别提供者在做出ADHD诊断时的自信程度，以及该提供者认为需要看到多严重的症状表现才能给出诊断。
So I definitely think there are individuals somewhere out there who are probably given a liberal diagnosis. On the other hand, I don't think that's an overwhelming trend of most people who have ADHD were given a diagnosis that's a stretch. I think one of the places we have to be most careful is when there's an incentive to have an ADHD diagnosis. And so you can see this in college students, for example, who I think in the last 10 to 15 years, we've seen this growth in college students who are pretty strategic, who go to the right provider and are able to get a prescription for a stimulant medication, which will help anyone study. It doesn't matter if you have ADHD or not, right? So that doesn't necessarily drive up our rates of ADHD diagnosis in the country alone,
所以我绝对认为外面确实有一些人可能被随意地给予了诊断。另一方面，我不认为大多数患有ADHD的人被给予了牵强的诊断，这并不是一种压倒性的趋势。我认为我们必须最谨慎的地方之一是当存在获得ADHD诊断的动机时。例如，你可以从大学生身上看到这一点，我认为在过去10到15年里，我们看到大学生群体中出现了这种增长，他们相当有策略，会去找合适的提供者并设法获得兴奋剂药物的处方，这会帮助任何人学习。无论你是否患有ADHD，这都有帮助，对吧？所以这并不一定单方面推高了我国ADHD的诊断率，
but there are certain subgroups where providers have to be careful and be very thorough when they're diagnosing because people may have ulterior motives for getting that diagnosis. So you mentioned medication as one of the treatment options. What are the various options that are available and are they different depending on age with for children, for adolescents, for adults? Yeah, I mean, overall, there's two categories of treatment. So one is the medications. Most of them are stimulant medications, though there are some non-stimulants. And then you're going to have your psychological treatments, which are, it's a CBT-like model in adults. And obviously when you're with younger
但在某些亚群体中，提供者在诊断时必须小心并非常彻底，因为人们可能有获得该诊断的不可告人的动机。所以你提到了药物作为治疗选择之一。有哪些可用的各种选择？它们是否因年龄而异，比如针对儿童、青少年和成人？是的，总的来说，治疗分为两类。一类是药物。大多数是兴奋剂药物，尽管也有一些非兴奋剂药物。然后是你的心理治疗，在成人中这是一种类似CBT（认知行为疗法）的模型。显然，当你面对更年轻的
children, it's going to be more of a behavior therapy parent training like model. But these two types of treatments do very different things. So if you take the medication, while it's in your system, it is going to directly intervene on that chemical dopamine, and it's going to directly help your cognition feel more under control. So if somebody hasn't taken a stimulant medication and they're curious what it feels like, it would be like having a really good cup of coffee with none of the jitters and none of the side effects, right? You have the focusability without the profile of things that kind of feel uncomfortable when you start giving yourself a stimulant. So if you can imagine that that helps people focus better and can control their cognition, but as soon as it wears off, the person
孩子时，它会更倾向于行为疗法和家长培训模型。但这两种治疗方法的作用非常不同。如果你服用药物，只要它在你的系统中，它就会直接干预多巴胺这种化学物质，并直接帮助你的认知感觉更受控制。所以如果有人没有服用过兴奋剂药物，并且好奇它是什么感觉，那就像喝了一杯非常好的咖啡，没有心悸，也没有副作用，对吧？你拥有了专注能力，而没有当你开始给自己服用兴奋剂时那种感觉不舒服的特征。所以如果你能想象这有助于人们更好地集中注意力并控制他们的认知，但一旦药效消失，这个人
is back to their normal self, still experiencing those ADHD symptoms. The cognitive behavioral treatments are going to work on a couple things, teaching people coping skills. So strategies for how they can stay organized. And when we're working with the parents of the younger kids, it's teaching the parents to set up routines and create situations that help people with ADHD function their best. And then also helping people with ADHD identify areas in their life that they might be able to be successful, what kinds of environments or settings are most conducive to them avoiding the impact of their symptoms. So whether that is for an adult, young adult, maybe trying to figure out what kind of educational or career path they want to go into, they might recognize that, you know what, I do best when I'm active, when I'm outside, when I'm working with my hands, I don't do as well sitting at a computer. and so helping people kind of get that self-awareness and make decisions to help them succeed. So both of those classes of treatments are effective.
又回到了他们正常的自我，仍然经历着那些ADHD症状。认知行为治疗将致力于几件事，教授人们应对技能。即关于他们如何保持组织性的策略。当我们与年幼孩子的父母一起工作时，是教导父母建立常规并创造有助于ADHD患者发挥最佳功能的环境。然后还帮助ADHD患者确定他们可能能够成功的领域，什么样的环境或设置最有利于他们避免症状的影响。所以无论是对于成人还是年轻人，也许试图弄清楚他们想进入什么样的教育或职业道路，他们可能会意识到，你知道吗，当我很活跃、在户外、用双手工作时，我表现得最好，坐在电脑前我表现得没那么好。所以帮助人们获得那种自我意识并做出决定来帮助他们成功。因此，这两类治疗都是有效的。
They help in complementary ways. I'm a big fan of doing both or trying both to sort of see how they can go hand in hand for an individual person. And ultimately, though, there's no right way to decide to get treated. Both of those options can be very helpful. So some children are diagnosed as early as three years old, which leads me to the question of, what's the earliest age at which it's considered to give any of these medications to children? So there's guidelines out there for giving medication to preschoolers, and that's about as young as you'll see it done. There's a lot of controversy out there about that.
它们以互补的方式提供帮助。我是同时进行或尝试两者的大力支持者，看看它们如何为个人相辅相成。但归根结底，没有决定接受治疗的“正确”方式。这两种选择都非常有帮助。所以有些孩子早在三岁就被诊断出来，这让我产生了一个问题：被认为给孩子服用这些药物的最早年龄是多少？关于给学龄前儿童服用药物有指导方针，这大约是你所能看到的最早年龄。关于这一点有很多争议。
I'm not a pediatrician, but I work with pediatricians, and I think a lot of pediatricians even feel uncomfortable giving that medication, and we'll refer to a psychiatrist or a specialist to really be careful before making a decision like that. for a young child. And I think one of the big reasons for that is because disruptive and hyperactive behavior is somewhat normative at that young age. And so it's really hard to tell the difference between somebody who's just, you know, a three-year-old and somebody who's actually got, you know, a chronic disorder. And so there's a lot of caution and just not wanting to misgive the, the stimulant medication. It's not because we think stimulant medication is harmful at that age. So, you know, you can diagnose ADHD and preschoolers, but I think there's less stability in that diagnosis when it's given that young because it's hard developmentally to decide who hasn't and who doesn't.
我不是儿科医生，但我与儿科医生合作，我认为许多儿科医生甚至对给予这种药物感到不舒服，并会转诊给精神科医生或专家，在为幼儿做出这样的决定之前真正谨慎行事。我认为其中一个很大的原因是，破坏性和多动行为在那个年轻的年龄在某种程度上是规范的。因此，很难区分一个只是三岁的孩子和一个真正患有慢性疾病的孩子。所以人们非常谨慎，只是不想错误地给予兴奋剂药物。这并不是因为我们认为兴奋剂药物在那个年龄是有害的。所以，你知道，你可以诊断学龄前儿童的ADHD，但我认为当诊断在那么小的时候给出时，其稳定性较低，因为在发育上很难决定谁有谁没有。
And then what do we know about the long-term effects of taking these medications? So if you start taking Adderall or, you know, whatever one of these medications might be as a child, how likely is it that you will have to take it for the rest of your life? and what do we know about what that might do to you physiologically? There's no definitive answer on this at all, but there's two areas of research ongoing and possible speculation on this. The first is on growth. So there is some evidence from some of the longitudinal studies that if you take stimulant medication for a prolonged period of time, it could affect your growth. This makes sense, right? Because the stimulant medications have a direct effect on appetite suppression. And so kids who are taking stimulant medications,
那么我们对长期服用这些药物的副作用了解多少？所以如果你在童年时期开始服用阿得拉（Adderall）或任何这些药物，你余生都需要服用它的可能性有多大？我们对它在生理上可能对你产生什么影响了解多少？对此根本没有定论，但有两个研究领域正在进行中，并可能对此进行推测。第一个是关于生长。确实有一些来自纵向研究的证据表明，如果你长期服用兴奋剂药物，它可能会影响你的生长。这说得通，对吧？因为兴奋剂药物对食欲抑制有直接影响。因此，一年中大部分时间都在服用兴奋剂药物的孩子
for most of the days of the year are getting less food intake and therefore that's less nutrients and therefore they're not growing as tall and as big as the kids who are not on these medications. So there's evidence that you can recover that growth somewhat by just not taking the medications over the summer, for example, or possibly, you know, taking holidays on the weekend. But also we're talking about in some of these studies, like less than two centimeters of adult height being impacted. So do people care about that level of growth? that's an open question. Some people may and some people may not. So that's one area. It's still a little
摄入的食物较少，因此营养也较少，因此他们长得不如那些没有服用这些药物的孩子高大。所以有证据表明，你可以通过在夏天不服用药物，或者可能在周末休息，来在一定程度上恢复这种生长。但我们也谈到在其中一些研究中，成年身高受到的影响不到两厘米。所以人们关心那种程度的生长吗？这是一个悬而未决的问题。有些人可能关心，有些人可能不关心。所以这是一个领域。它仍然有点
controversial because some of the findings are mixed, but something is probably there with that. The other area is whether or not people somehow are going to be more interested in using substances or drugs as adults because they took this medication as children. And so there's been work investigating that and overall it suggests that, no, that is not the case. If people take stimulant medications as children, it does not make them more likely to want to use drugs as adults. So, you know, that I think is pretty thoroughly researched. There is work investigating the idea of tolerance and ADHD medications. The idea that if you take medications for ADHD for a while, they start to wear off how effective they are on you. And there is some evidence to suggest that may happen,
有争议，因为一些发现是混合的，但其中可能确实存在一些东西。另一个领域是人们是否会因为在童年时期服用这种药物而在成年后对使用物质或毒品更感兴趣。因此，已经有研究在调查这一点，总的来说，它表明，不，情况并非如此。如果人们在童年时期服用兴奋剂药物，并不会使他们在成年后更有可能想要使用毒品。所以，你知道，我认为这已经得到了相当彻底的研究。有研究在调查ADHD药物耐药性的想法。即如果你服用ADHD药物一段时间，它们对你的有效性开始减弱。确实有一些证据表明这可能会发生，
and that it may be one of the main reasons why people with ADHD after several years start wanting to stop taking them, because they may not feel like they help as much as they used to do. And this is an interesting research question that people are still looking at, whether it has to do with the fact that it's a ratio of how much you weigh to how much of the pill you take and how many milligrams of the chemical you put in your body. And as people grow up, technically you need to take more and more to keep the ratio of how much you weigh to how much chemical in balance. But we have limits in the country about how big of doses we give people. So there is also kind of this concern of people developing over time kind of a tolerance of the medication.
而且这可能是ADHD患者在几年后开始想要停止服用它们的主要原因之一，因为他们可能觉得它们不像以前那样有帮助了。这是一个有趣的研究问题，人们仍在研究，它是否与你的体重与你服用的药丸量以及你身体中摄入的化学物质毫克数之间的比例有关。随着人们长大，从技术上讲，你需要服用越来越多来保持体重与化学物质的平衡。但我们在国内对给予人们的剂量大小有限制。所以这也存在一种人们随着时间推移对药物产生某种耐药性的担忧。
And can you keep upping the dose to keep the medication working? And at some point maybe you can't. So it could be the case that we can't really see a good effective medication for decades and decades because eventually someone hits a ceiling where, you know, its effects are lessened. Research has shown that people with ADHD are at risk for a number of bad outcomes in their lives and co-occurring disorders such as depression, addiction, and even suicide. Why is that and how can treatment help?
那么你能不断增加剂量以保持药物有效吗？在某个时候也许你不能。所以情况可能是，我们几十年来都无法真正看到一种好的有效药物，因为最终有人会达到一个上限，你知道，它的效果会减弱。研究表明，ADHD患者在生活中面临许多不良后果的风险，以及共存疾病，如抑郁、成瘾甚至自杀。为什么会这样？治疗如何提供帮助？
Well, ADHD is one of the biggest risk factors, like you say, for a lot of different negative outcomes. And if you think about it, people with ADHD have trouble with self-control as sort of the main feature of their disorder. So they're going to have trouble sometimes with decision-making carefully. They also have trouble with risky behaviors because they have trouble with delaying their gratification and being patient for things. And if they want something, sometimes they don't think about the consequences and they just go for it. So you see some risky behavior going on there. Another potential mechanism of this is people with ADHD unfortunately experience a lot of negative experiences in their life because they aren't as good at school as other kids sometimes.
嗯，正如你所说，ADHD是许多不同负面后果的最大风险因素之一。如果你仔细想想，ADHD患者的主要疾病特征是自我控制困难。所以他们有时在谨慎决策方面会有困难。他们也因为难以延迟满足和对事物缺乏耐心而容易出现冒险行为。如果他们想要什么，有时他们不会考虑后果，只是直接去做。所以你会看到那里发生了一些冒险行为。这种机制的另一个潜在因素是，ADHD患者不幸在生活中经历了许多负面体验，因为他们有时在学校不如其他孩子表现好。
They don't have as many friends and they start to feel kind of bad about themselves. They're getting a lot of negative feedback about the environment. And so that can help or that can lead to the development of self-esteem issues and other difficulties that can lead to things like depression and anxiety. So you can see there's sort of like, like, like a cocktail brewing here where not only do you have your ADHD symptoms, but some of the life experiences that come as a result of your ADHD symptoms create additional problems, and it kind of can snowball for people if they don't get on the right track and have the right supports in their life. And a big part of getting people treated when they're kids, when
他们没有那么多朋友，开始对自己感觉不好。他们从环境中得到了很多负面反馈。因此，这可能导致自尊问题的产生以及其他可能导致抑郁和焦虑等问题的困难。所以你可以看到这里就像有一种鸡尾酒在酝酿，不仅你有ADHD症状，而且由于你的ADHD症状而产生的一些生活经历创造了额外的问题，如果人们没有走上正轨并在生活中得到正确的支持，它可能会像滚雪球一样。而让人们在童年、青少年甚至成年时得到治疗的一个重要部分，
they're teenagers, even when they're adults, is to help people kind of be aware of those risks and help them make good decisions to stay away from them. That makes a lot of sense. So it's not ADHD itself, it's the reaction to it by the community at large, if you will. That's definitely a factor. So now that awareness is growing that ADHD can be a lifelong disorder, are there resources out there for adults who suspect that they might have it? Where should adults go to get information? Well, I think the best resource, public resource out there is the Chad website for children
是帮助人们意识到这些风险，并帮助他们做出正确的决定以远离它们。这很有道理。所以这不是ADHD本身，而是整个社区对它的反应。这绝对是一个因素。既然人们越来越意识到ADHD可能是一种终身疾病，那么对于怀疑自己可能患有此病的成年人来说，是否有资源？成年人应该去哪里获取信息？嗯，我认为最好的公共资源是CHADD网站，即“注意力缺陷多动障碍儿童与成人协会”。这是与ADHD相关的倡导组织之一，与疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）合作，为人们提供良好的信息。所以如果你想知道你是否患有ADHD，或者如果你想了解更多关于这种疾病的信息、它是什么样的以及你的选择是什么，一定要查看CHADD网站，这是一个很好的起点。
and adults with attention deficit hyperactivity disorder. This is one of the advocacy organizations for ADHD that is partnered with the Center for Disease Control, CDC, on getting good information out there for folks. So if you're wondering if you have ADHD or if you want to find out more about the disorder and what it's like and what your options are, definitely check out the Chad C-H-A-D-D website, and that's a great starting place. Good, good, thank you. So, of course, in every podcast lately, we have to ask a question. related to the pandemic and here's yours. There have been a number of news articles in the past year that indicate that the pandemic has caused an uptick in ADHD diagnoses and parents seeking information about ADHD because
好的，谢谢。当然，最近在每个播客中，我们都必须问一个与疫情相关的问题，这是你的问题。过去一年里有许多新闻文章指出，疫情导致了ADHD诊断的增加，以及父母因学校中断和孩子整天待在家里而寻求有关ADHD的信息。这与你在临床研究和实践中看到的情况一致吗？是的，绝对一致。所以想想看。ADHD是一个连续体，这意味着有些人显然患有非常严重的ADHD，而另一些人可能患有轻微的ADHD，甚至只是可能在条件合适时被加剧或恶化的ADHD倾向。而其中一个条件，特别是对于可能有点注意力不集中
of school disruptions and having their kids in the house all day. Does this track with what you've been seeing in your clinical research and in your practice? Yeah, absolutely. So think about this. ADHD is on a continuum, which means there are some people who clearly have very severe ADHD. and there are other people who might have a mild version of ADHD or even just tendencies towards ADHD that could potentially get exacerbated or worsened if the right conditions are in place. And one of the conditions, especially for kids and teens who might be a little inattentive
或在组织和拖延方面有点困难的儿童和青少年来说，就是失去学校日常的结构，整天待在一个固定的地方，坐在电脑前，试图在没有老师支持或无法以身体方式与其他孩子互动的情况下完成工作。因此，这些条件我认为导致许多患有轻度ADHD的人看到了比平时更严重的症状。这使他们引起了临床关注，而在以前，也许他们不会被注意到。所以我们已经看到，你知道，我在研究和临床上都看到了，更多的人进来，想知道他们是否能从药物中受益，特别是在这段时间寻求ADHD的服务。
or have a little trouble with organization and procrastination, would be losing the structure of your school day and just being in one stationary place all day in front of a computer, you know, trying to get your work done without the support of a teacher or the ability to interact with other kids in a physical way. And so those conditions, I think, have led many people with milder ADHD to see more severe symptoms than they're usually having. And that's brought them to clinical attention where before maybe they wouldn't have been. So we have been seeing, you know, I've seen it both in the research and also clinically more people coming in, wondering if they, you know, could benefit from medication and particularly seeking out services for ADHD during
最后一个问题，你认为目前关于ADHD最大的悬而未决的问题是什么？因此，你在研究中正在做什么？我认为最大的悬而未决的问题之一是，我们如何将有效的治疗方法提供给真正需要它们的人，特别是资源匮乏情况下的群体，那些可能经历各种逆境的孩子。所以如果你患有ADHD，并且生活中经历逆境，你可能（你知道）在双重挣扎。因此，这一直是一种疾病，你知道，那些经常去看儿科医生或有资源去看私人心理医生的人一直能够获得护理。
this time. So last question, what do you think are the biggest open questions about ADHD right now? And as a result, what are you working on in your research? I think one of the biggest open questions is how do we get treatments that are effective out there to people who really need them, especially people in low resource situations, kids who maybe, you know, experience various adversities. And so if you have ADHD and you have adversity in your life, you're probably, you know, doubly, you know, struggling. And so it's been a disorder that, you know, people who regularly go into their pediatrician or have the resources to go see a private psychologist have always been able to access care for.
但是，你知道，我在公立学校和社区心理健康中心做了很多工作，试图看看我们如何培训人们以资源匮乏的方式进行有效的治疗。因为我认为预防对于这种疾病来说就是一切。如果你能尽早控制症状，你确实可以避免许多那些负面后果。我还认为拼图的另一部分是更加关注可能导致症状波动或下降的环境因素。因为如果我们能确定有助于人们症状保持在受控状态或至少部分缓解在亚临床范围内的因素，那么我们就有可能进行干预，帮助利用这些因素。所以我们需要（你知道）对ADHD患者进行更多的访谈和研究体验，以发现他们生活中感觉自己做得好的模式，然后为人们利用这一点。
But, you know, I do a lot of work in public schools and community mental health centers trying to see how we could train folks to be able to do effective treatments, you know, in lower resource ways. Because I think prevention is everything with this disorder. If you can control the symptoms early, you do avoid a lot of those negative outcomes. I also think another piece of the puzzle is a bigger focus on the environmental factors that can lead the symptoms to go up or down. Because if we could identify factors that can help people's symptoms stay at bay or, you
好的，感谢您今天加入我，西布利博士。我相信我们的听众会发现您的见解非常有帮助。谢谢。谢谢。您可以在www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目，请给我们留下评论。
know, at least partially remitted in a subclinical range, then we potentially can make interventions that can help harness those factors. So we need to be, you know, getting more interviews in and more research experiences in with people with ADHD to find the patterns in their life of when they feel they do well and then leveraging that for people. Well, thank you for joining me today, Dr. Sibley. I'm sure that our listeners are going to find your insights very, very helpful. Thank you. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts, and please leave us a review.
如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的音频编辑是Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。